so much for this dream middle class and
my mom keeps telling me we're supposed
to be grateful my mom doesn't understand
because she's like you got a bike you
got a roof over your head you got food
every day and I'm not satisfied and so
I'm starting to make decisions right now
I'm Gonna Get Rich one day deciding what
it is you want out of life what is your
life plan what do you want your life to
be is the most important thing you can
decide on an obsession is what people
need to find success I think they also
need to have this constant and
never-ending striving for improvement I
don't care who you are I don't care how
successful you are you are going to
doubt everything every step of the way
that is why faith is so important and
literally the hardest one to master what
the mind can conceive and believe it can
achieve